THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
♪ ♪
>> Dana: PEACE TALKS WITH THE
TALIBAN ARE CANCELED.
TRUMP CANCELED.
TRUMP, PULLING THE PLUG AFTER
TALIBAN LEADERS CLAIM
RESPONSIBILITY FOR AN ATTACK
THAT KILLED A U.S. SOLDIER AND
11 OTHERS.
THE TALLY BAND, RESPONDING TO
THE PRESIDENT'S MOVE BY
THREATENING MORE AMERICANS WILL
DIE AS A RESULT.
LET'S WATCH.
>> IS JUST ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF
THE PRESIDENT TREATING FOREIGN
POLICY LOOK AT SOME KIND OF GAME
SHOW.
>> DONALD TRUMP IS NOT AFRAID TO
WALK AWAY FROM A BAD DEAL.
>> THIS IS THE WORST PRESIDENT
WHEN IT COMES TO NEGOTIATING.
IT'S MORE OF HIS ERRATIC
BEHAVIOR THAT PEOPLE ARE TIRED
OF.
>> I THINK THE PRESIDENT WAS
RIGHT TO CANCEL THE MEETING.
I THINK WHAT HE'S TRYING TO DO
IS FULFILL A CAMPAIGN PROMISE.
>> FOR THE U.S. TO MEET WITH THE
TALIBAN AND NOT HAVE THE LEADER
OF AFGHANISTAN TO MEET WITH THE
TALIBAN AM, IT'S SOMETHING
THAT'S DOOMED TO FAILURE.
>> Dana: PRESIDENT TRUMP,
CALLING OFF FUTURE TALKS WITH
THE TALIBAN, AND DEFENDED TRYING
TO HAVE THEM IN THE FIRST PLACE.
>> President Trump: THEY
THOUGHT THAT THEY HAD TO KILL
PEOPLE TO PUT THEMSELVES IN A
LITTLE BETTER NEGOTIATING
POSITION.
YOU CAN'T DO THAT.
YOU CAN'T DO THAT WITH ME.
THAT'S IT AS FAR AS I'M
CONCERNED.
I LIKE THE IDEA OF MEETING.
I'VE MET WITH A LOT OF BAD
PEOPLE AND A LOT OF GOOD PEOPLE
DURING THE COURSE OF THE LAST
ALMOST THREE YEARS.
I THINK MEETING IS A GREAT
THING.
I THINK THAT MEETING WITH, YOU
KNOW, YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT WAR.
THERE ARE MEETINGS WITH WAR
OTHERWISE WARS WOULD NEVER END.
YOU'D HAVE THEM GO ON FOREVER.
WE HAVE A MEETING SCHEDULED.
IT WAS MY IDEA AND IT WAS MY
IDEA TO TERMINATE IT.
>> Dana: HE IS THE DECIDER.
THE TELE- BAND WAS SET UP FOR AN
INCREDIBLE PROPAGANDA
OPPORTUNITY AT CAMP DAVID.
THEY BLEW IT.
SO THEIR ARROGANCE MIGHT HAVE
DONE THEM IN, BUT MAYBE THAT'S
GOOD.
>> A COUPLE OF THINGS.
THE ATTACKS WERE HAPPENING AT A
PRETTY STEADY BASIS.
WE WERE ATTACKING THEM TOO.
WE CAN MOVE ABOUT A THOUSAND
PEOPLE OVER THE LAST MONTH.
I THINK THE TALIBAN WAS GETTING
A LITTLE BELLIGERENT.
THE PRESIDENT SAID THAT HE
WANTED TO MEET WITH THE TALIBAN.
THEY WANTED TO GO HAVE A
CEREMONY, SAYING, HEY, LOOK WHAT
I DID.
THE PRESIDENT SAID, HEY I DON'T
WANT A CELEBRATION.
I WANT TO LOOK THESE GUYS IN THE
EYE AND SEE IF THEY ARE SERIOUS
ABOUT TAKING THE NEXT STEP.
IT WAS HIS IDEA TO GO TO
CAMP DAVID.
IT WAS POMPEO WHO PUT THE TALKS
TOGETHER.
THEY ARE NOT READY TO TALK PEAC
PEACE.
THEY WERE ALREADY SUCCESSFUL.
THAT WAS THE TALK IN BETWEEN
SESSIONS.
CLEARLY THEY DID.
>> Dana: JUSTLY, THERE ARE TWO
NARRATIVES.
THIS WAR HAS GONE ON TOO LONG.
WE THINK THIS IS THE WAY
FORWARD.
THE TALIBAN WAS BASICALLY
SAYING, WE HAVE RUN OFF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
AREN'T WE GREAT.
THOSE TWO THINGS WERE NEVER
GOING TO BE ABLE TO REMAIN
WITHOUT COLLIDING AT SOME POINT.
>> Jesse: I DON'T LIKE THE
SYMBOLISM OF THE TALIBAN COMING
TO CAMP DAVID.
IT'S HALLOWED GROUND.
THESE PEOPLE ARE BARBARIC.
THEY MAKE KIM JONG UN LOOK TAME.
THEY PERSONALLY COMMIT
ATROCITIES.
THEY PERSONALLY DO HORRIBLE
HORRIBLE THINGS.
YOU CAN'T EVEN SAY THEM HERE ON
TELEVISION.
SO TO GIVE THEM THAT CAMP DAVID
PLATFORM I THINK WAS A BAD IDEA
AND I'M GLAD THE PRESIDENT
CANCELED IT.
WE HAVE HAD BAD GUYS AT
CAMP DAVID BEFORE.
I UNDERSTAND THE PRESIDENT
WANTING TO WITHDRAW FROM
AFGHANISTAN.
ALL POWERS EVENTUALLY FIGHT
THERE AND THEN THEY LEAVE.
WE JUST WANT TO LEAVE ON HER OWN
TERMS AND I BELIEVE HIS
STRATEGISTS WERE TRYING TO LOCK
THOSE TERMS IN SO THEY COULD
LEAVE WITH SOME SENSE OF
ACCOMPLISHMENT.
BUT ALSO, NOT JUST LEAVE
AFGHANISTAN FOR TERRORISTS TO
RECONSTITUTE THEMSELVES AND MAKE
ATTACKS HERE.
WANT TO BE A LONG PROCESS AND WE
NEED TO DO SOMETHING TO END THIS
WAR AND SPENT THE TENS OF
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT WE ARE
SPENDING THERE, HAVE IT SPENT
HERE.
>> Dana: ONE OF THE THINGS, IS
THAT THEY REFUSED TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT THE TALIBAN WAS RESPONSIBLE
FOR 9/11.
>> Juan: WE HAVEN'T SET IT,
BUT THIS WEEK IS THE ANNIVERSAR
ANNIVERSARY.
I THINK IT'S NOW AT 18 YEARS
SINCE 9/11.
THE IDEA THAT THE PRESIDENT
WOULD INVITE THESE PEOPLE, WHO
WERE THE HOST FOR THE TERRORISTS
WHO ATTACKED TO COME TO THIS
COUNTRY.
I FIND THAT INCREDIBLE.
I DON'T THINK THAT WAS POMPEO.
IT WAS THE PRESIDENT.
NO.
I THINK YOU ARE SAYING, HEY,
WAIT.
THERE WERE OTHER PEOPLE PUTTING
THINGS TOGETHER.
I THINK HE'S THE GUY.
HE'S THE GUY.
HE APPROVED OF THIS IDEA, WHICH
I FIND --
'S BEFORE THERE WAS A HUGE
OUTRAGE AGAINST THAT.
I DON'T THINK PEOPLE ALSO
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS WAS NOT THE
RIGHT TIME.
>> Juan: BOOK, I JUST THINK
THERE'S A HUGE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN SAYING, WE ARE GOING TO
PUT PEOPLE ON TRIAL, VERSUS
WHAT WE SAW HERE, WHICH IS BRING
THEM IN.
>> Jesse: I AGREE.
I DON'T THINK IT WAS THE RIGHT
PLACE TO DO IT.
I THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WANT
US OVER.
I THINK TRUMP HAS THE RIGHT
INSTINCT THERE.
BUT WHEN YOU STOP AND THINK
ABOUT THE IDEA THAT YOU ARE
GIVING CREDIBILITY TO PEOPLE FOR
TERRORISTS AND THEY DON'T EVEN
HAVE A DEAL WITH THE GOVERNMENT.
THEIR OWN GOVERNMENT.
YOU SAW WHAT HAPPENED WHEN THE
SOVIETS PULLED BACK.
IT JUST LED TO CHAOS AND MORE
TERRORISTS TAKING ROOT THERE.
HOW CAN WE INVITE THESE GUYS
WHEN WE ARE SAYING TO THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE FLEEING THE BAHAMAS AND
THE DEVASTATION, OH, YOU CAN'T
COME HERE.
THAT'S AN OUTRAGE.
>> Dana: THOSE ARE TWO VERY
DIFFERENT THINGS.
I WANT TO ASK ABOUT THE
INVESTMENT AND RETURN ON
INVESTMENT THAT WE HAVE ACHIEVED
OVER THE LAST 18 YEARS.
THE ABILITY FOR WOMEN AND
CHILDREN TO BE ABLE TO GO TO
SCHOOL AND NOT BE AFRAID FOR
THEIR LIVES, EVEN THOUGH THAT'S
NOT TRUE ACROSS THE BOARD.
AND ALSO, TO BE ABLE TO PREVENT
AL QAEDA FROM BEING ABLE TO
ATTACK US FROM THERE.
THAT HAS PAID OFFENSE SOME WAY.
BECAUSE IF YOU PULL OFF OF
AFGHANISTAN, YOU EXPOSE THE U.S.
PART OF IT MAY BE TO ACCEPT THE
FIGHT AGAINST ISLAMIC TERRORISM
WOULD BE A MULTIGENERATIONAL
STRUGGLE AROUND THE WORLD.
BETTER TO STAY ON OFFENSE THEN
TO RETREAT TO PLAYING DEFENSE ON
AMERICA'S.
FAR BETTER TO HAVE MUSLIM ALLIES
ON OUR SIDE.
MISSILE ATTACKS DO NOT STOP
AL QAEDA.
TO JESSE'S POINT, I KNOW A LOT
OF AMERICANS PROBABLY WENT, "OH
HELL NO."
>> ALL THE PRESIDENT HAS TO DO
IS SAY, I'M GOING TO DRAW DOWN,
BUT I CAN'T PULL OUT, BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED IN IRAQ.
I FINISH IT IN 2017.
I GOT ASKED TO BECOME
SECRETARY OF DEFENSE.
HE SAID, THEY TOLD
VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN AND HIS
DIGNITARIES, THEY SAID, IF YOU
PULL OUT, THERE'S AN AL QAEDA
GROUP READY TO MOVE IN.
THEY PULLED OUT ANYWAY.
WHEN THE PRESIDENT PULLS OUT,
HE'S NOT NOT SAYING I WANT TO
DUMB
TAKE OVER THE COUNTRY.
THAT GIVES US AN IDEA OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING ON THE GROUND LOVE
AL QAEDA AND ALL THE TERRORIST
ACTIVITIES THAT ARE GOING ACROSS
THE PAKISTAN AFGHANI BORDER.
IF YOU WANT TO GET MORE ALLIES
INVOLVED, ABSOLUTELY.
BUT THE PRESIDENT JUST EXPLAINED
THAT IT'S NOT ABOUT AFGHANISTAN.
IT'S ABOUT A SPYGLASS INTO THE
TERROR NETWORKS THAT ARE
EXISTING AND THRIVING THERE.
WE GET COUNTLESS BENEFITS FROM
BEING THERE AND UNDERSTANDING
HOW THEY OPERATE.
>> Jesse: THAT'S AN IMPORTANT
POINT IS THAT YOU WERE LEAVING A
COUNTER TERRORIST IN THERE TO
LAUNCH OPERATIONS AND ALSO GAIN
INTELLIGENCE.
BUT ALSO, MAYBE LEAVE SOME SMART
PEOPLE.
MAYBE WE COULD GET PAID BACK FOR
ALL THE WORK.
>> Juan: 18 YEARS.
18 YEARS WE'VE BEEN THERE.
18 YEARS, THREE PRESIDENTS.
I THINK WE'VE GOT 2300 AMERICANS
DEAD.
3500, IF YOU INCLUDE THE ALLIED
FORCES.
I THINK IT'S TIME FOR US TO
THINK ABOUT HOW WE HANDLE THIS,
BECAUSE WE ARE NOT THERE TO STAY
FOREVER.
>> I KNOW THESE ARE TWO
DIFFERENT THINGS, BUT WE'VE HAD
TROOPS IN EUROPE SINCE THE END